sur un anniversaire aujourd'hui la
contraception à 10 ans et oui
souvenez-vous après des années de
clandestinité des discussions morale
assez âpre scientifique politique le
parlement finissez par adopté en juin 67
la première loi sur la contraception
depuis les mentalités ont beaucoup
changé les techniques se sont améliorées
l'appui leur en bourse
je crois que j'avais la peine de faire
le point aujourd'hui les pionniers chez
de la régulation des naissances ont
lancé à l'initiative de cette revue
contraception fertilité sexualité un
bilan de dix années d'expérience il est
positif mais vous allez le voir il y a
encore beaucoup peint en france une
femme sur quatre en âge d'avoir des
enfants prend la pilule mais c'est très
récent
rappelez vous il ya un peu plus de dix
ans seulement et vit d'abord une période
très héroïque ou parler de contraception
était véritablement un acte risquait
vous pour un médecin formuler une
prescription réceptifs et est également
quelque chose de risqué et puis peu à
peu la prescription de contraceptifs
s'est généralisé mais la contraception
devait encore passer le terrible barrage
du parlement en 1967 elle était
officiellement reconnue et en 74
remboursés par la sécurité sociale
aujourd'hui les femmes qui veulent
espacer les naissances dispose de
plusieurs moyens d'abord les pilules
elles sont mieux adaptés avec des doses
d'hormones beaucoup plus faible qu'au
début elle garantit cependant un
résultat 100 % et diminue de beaucoup
certains inconvénients comme la prise de
poids ensuite les stérilets en plastique
est maintenant en
placé dans l'utérus de la femme et qui
s'oppose à ce que l'embryon qui se
nichait dans la paroisse stérilet d
avantage certain en ce sens qu'il ne
nécessite chez la femme
une motivation unique au départ et
qu'ensuite il va de soi qu'elle n'a plus
à s'en soucier
le stérilet si je puis dire travaillent
pour elles les formes de stérilet au
cuivre aujourd'hui peuvent être réduits
de manière linéaire de telle sorte que
lorsque les gynécologues l'estimé utile
il peut être inséré aux femmes qui l'ont
poserait une enfant puisque le volume
est très petit c'est l'intérêt de cette
technique mais il ya des inconvénients
il n'y a pas de bonne méthode pour
inconvénient c'est une ville ou à de la
médecine et les inconvénients sont que
parfois effectivement les règles des
femmes sont un peu longues
les autres effets secondaires
aujourd'hui sont pratiquement résorbé
par rapport aux ancêtres stérile et du
fait que le stérilet au cuivre dont on
dispose et d'un volume plus petit et que
l'efficacité est imputable cuivre les
moyens mécaniques sont soit les
préservatifs masculins soit le
diaphragme où les spermicides que
mettent les femmes et ses moyens qui
donnait 6 7 8 % d'échec se perfectionne
actuellement et on arrive actuellement
avec les produits spermicide nouveau à
taux d'échec qui n'est plus que de 4 %
environ
si bien qu'on revient à peu aux moyens
mécaniques chez les femmes qui pour
lesquelles l'idée d'une d'un échec au
fond n'est pas catastrophique
en réalité tout les français sont encore
loin de revendiquer pour la libre
maternité deux tiers d'entre elles n'ont
pas recours à la contraception
certaines résistances sont inhérents à
l'ignorance on en a beaucoup parlé c'est
le manque d'information mais certaines
résistantes sont inhérentes à la nature
féminine
parce que pour certaines femmes le
plaisir est forcément associé à l'idée
de maternité et il y à la psychologie
semant quelque chose qui est très
difficile à vaincre ce problème n'est
pas propre à la france
nos voisins européens mais surtout les
nations dont la démographie est
galopante éprouve comme nous le besoin
d'informer d'éduquer et aussi de
recourir à des méthodes plus radicales
l'avortement pis-aller la stérilisation
irréversible ou même pour l'avenir le
vaccin contraceptifs vaccin si grossesse
est en ce moment en cours d'étude en
inde et aux états unis
mais ce que nous savons des travaux
actuels fait penser que ce ne sera pas
une solution de contraception à 100% ça
pourrait être une méthode utilisée dans
un pays qui cherche à diminuer la
démographie parce qu'il y aura une
efficacité à 90 à 98 %
mais ce ne sera pas une méthode que
chaque fin de vie sera utilisé pour elle
même car ce qu'elle ne sera pas protégé
à 100 pour ça de toute façon avant la
mise au point de ce vaccin
les médecins devront régler les
problèmes particuliers et plus pressé de
la contraception des jeunes pour
lesquels aucune méthode n'est
actuellement très bien adapté